خلال الازمه القى خطابا وصف بالاستثنائي
ثم صمت الى ان هدات الاوضاع الرئيس الروسي
وفلاديمير بوتين رجل الاستخبارات العتيق
يخرج عن صمته بعد انتهاء التمرد المسلح
لتتعدد لقاءاته وخطاباته احدثها امام
ممثلين عن اجهزته الامنيه كشف خلالها
بوتين عن تفاصيل دعم سلطات بلاده لمجموعه
فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه
اود الاشاره الى ان افراد مجموعه فاجنر
كانوا يتمتعون بدعم حكومي منذ مايو 2022
وقوات فاجنر تلقت اكثر من مليار دولار منذ
مايو 2022
والتمويل كان من مخصصات وزاره الدفاع
لكن بوتين توعد بفتح تحقيق لمعرفه كيفيه
صرف قائد فاغنر لتلك الاموال وفي خطاب اخر
شكر الرئيس الروسي قوات الامن والحرس
الوطني والجيش لمنع حرب اهليه وانهاء تمرد
فاغنر دون خسائر تذكر بوتين ايضا لزم
دقيقه صمت تحيه لذكرى طيارين بالجيش قتلوا
خلال التمرد
ورغم تكرار بوتين تنديده بما وصفها
بالخيانه لكنه حافظ على الخيارات الثلاثه
المطروحه امام مقاتل فاجنر سواء بالعوده
الى منازلهم او الاندماج في الجيش النظامي
او التوجه الى بيلاروسيا التي عمل رئيسها
الكسندر لوكاشنكا كوسيط لانهاء التمرد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات